[音楽]
ありがとうございます皆さんこんにちはえ
大変偉大なスピーカーの後ですごく緊張し
ていますちょっと勘弁してくれると思って
ます今日は
え皆様の貴重な時間を借りてお話をします
みんに出ようというお話です冒険と言って
もRPGゲームのような冒険ではありませ
ん自分の殻を破るための冒険です僕には
世界をまたにかけるようなそんなお話は
できませんでも僕はあえあなたが半径2m
から冒険に出られるようそんなお話をさせ
ていただき
ます
僕には言葉に詰まる基音という障害
があります喋ることがすごく苦手なんです
例えばありがとうございましたの5の字を
言うのが僕は
すごく苦手なんですでも今日回り立ってお
話をさせていただきますこれは僕にとって
自分の殻を破る冒険でもあります一生懸命
お話をしますので最後まで聞いて聞いて
いただけ
たら嬉しいですそしてこの話を聞いた
あなたも冒険に出て欲しいと思っています
是非このトークの後隣に座ってる知らない
方にお話をしてしていただけたら嬉しい
ですさてえ僕は大塚修平と言います東京都
の江戸川区というところで子供たちに運動
を教える仕事をしています保育園の体操の
先生をしたりスポーツクラブのコーチをし
たりしています毎週200人から300人
ぐらいの子供たちに運動を教えています
こうやって言葉に詰まるけどそれでも喋っ
て一生懸命え運動を教えていますまた会社
では
ゆYouTubeもしてい
ますYouTubeではおすすめの運動の
メニューを紹介しています
これも言葉に詰まり
ながら喋ってえ運動を教えていますこう
やって子供たちの前で喋ったり
YouTubeで喋ったりとにかく喋り
まくっているんですけれども僕は基音と
いう言葉につまる障害があり
ます吉音は
緊張しているから言葉に詰まるわけではあ
ありません緊張をしていてもしていなくて
も言葉に詰まってしまうの
です吉音者は人口の1%いると言われてい
ますこここの会場にはおよそ100名
いらっしゃるということなのでおそらくお
1人は僕と同じ質問者がいらっしゃること
かなと思い
ます
え吉音には主に3つの症状があると
言われています連発と言ってああ
あありがとうと言葉を繰り返してしまう
こと新発と言ってあありがとうと言葉が
伸びてしまうこと難発と言っ
てと何も出なくなっ
てしまうことこの3つが吉音の主な症状だ
と言われていますこれでも僕のキツは
とっても軽い方なんですけれどもそれでも
連発新発難発この3つの症状全てが出
ます質問者はこの3つの症状が出るだけ
ならまだいいです1番恐ろしいのはうまく
喋れなかったらどうしよう
と喋ることを避けてしまうことなんですね
でコミュニケーションを避け
てしまうと人と人の距離
がち縮まること
はありませんこれが最も恐ろしい
です僕もこの吉音のせいで一時期喋ること
が嫌いでし
たでも今は子供たちの前で運動を教え
たりYouTubeで喋ったりそして今日
このような舞台でおおお話をさせてい
いただけるようになりましたこれは僕が
吉音で喋ることが苦手だったからこそ
いただけたチャンスだなと思ってい
ます今子供たちの前で運動を教えていると
やっぱり言葉に詰まってしまうんですね
そうすると子供たちは僕に聞いてき
ますねえねえ平こ
なんで周平コチは言葉に詰まる
のその時僕は既のことを教えるチャンスだ
と思ってなるべく丁寧に説明をするように
してい
ます言葉に詰まるのは基音という障害を
持ってるからという
こと基音者は100人に1人はいるんだと
いうことそういう人がもし君の周りにい
たら最後まで話を聞いてあげてほしいと
いうこと
この内容を5分ぐらい時間をかかけてえ
熱弁するんですけれどもそそうすると
決まって子供たちはふーんと言って2秒
で僕の元から走り去っていっちゃいます君
から聞いてきたのにってあのがっかりする
んですけど
もでも次第にその子たちは僕の話を最後
まで聞いてくれるように変わっていくん
ですねおそらく
その子たちは僕私とは違う人がいるんだな
ということを理解してくれるようなん
です社会には喋ることが少ない仕事も
たくさんあります僕はそういった仕事を
することもできましたでも僕は喋ることを
仕事に選んできまし
たそれは
質問者だからこそ社会には色々な人がいて
いいんだよそういうことを伝えられると
そういう風に思ったからなん
ですキだから感じてきたこと
があり
ます吉音だから出会えた人がい
ます吉音だから伝えられることがあり
ます今や吉音は僕にとっての強み
です喋る仕事につくという冒険に出た結果
僕が強みを1つ増やすことができましただ
からあなたにも冒険に出て欲しいと思って
いるの
ですさて今強みと言いましたが強み
て何でしょうねこれ調べてみたら強い点
頼りにできるところだそうですじゃ反対に
弱みって何でしょうこれも調べてみたら
弱点他人に対して後ろめたいと思っている
ところだそう
です僕の吉音は弱みでしょうか僕は今吉音
があるからこそ社会には色々な人がいて
いいんだよということ
を伝えることができていますそう考えたら
僕の吉音は強みなのかもしれませ
ん例えばこれが運動だったらどうでしょう
ね僕は今運動を教える仕事をしているん
ですけれども運動が得意だと思ったことは
実は1度もありません本当です
これ例えば高校生の頃僕は野球部に入っ
ていました部員が100人ぐらいいる東京
の
中1年生の終わりの頃に僕は監督に
呼び出されまし
た大塚君君は選手を引退してマネージャー
をして
くれ
ガーあのこれ本当の話なんですけれども
それ
くらい僕は選手としてはは戦力外でした
それくらい僕は運動が得意ではありません
でも今運動を教える仕事
をしていますそうすることで僕にできる
ことが1つ増えましたそれ
は運動が得意ではない子の気持ちに
寄り添うことなん
です運動が得意ではないけど運動を教える
仕事につくそういう冒険に出ることで僕は
強みををまた1つ増やすことができました
実は人が持ってる弱みというのは考え方を
変えれば強みに変わっていくのかもしれ
ませ
ん僕の友達に弱みを強みに変えたご夫婦が
いいらっしゃい
ます
美川たけしさん美賀さんと言います
お2人にはえお姉ちゃんと双子の男の子と
いう3人のお子様がいらっしゃいます双子
のお兄ちゃんの方は笑顔が素敵なレタ君と
言い
ますレタは
え脳性麻痺を持って生まれてきましたその
え影響で歩くことも喋ることも食事も
トイレも自分でコントロールすることは
難しい
です
僕は中学校に通う彼を1年間サポートさせ
ていただきまし
たデータは障害の影響で日に日にこの関節
と筋肉が固まっていってしまうんですねだ
から毎日数人でこの関節と筋肉を
伸ばすストレッチをする必要がありまし
たたさんとミガさんはそれをずっと続けて
いく必要がありましたでもこれを家族だけ
で続けていこうとすると家族が疲れて倒れ
てしまうんです
ねだ
からたけしさんと美香さんは冒険
に出ましたレタに障害があることを公表し
て徐々に地域の人たちを巻き込むという
冒険に出たの
ですそのボランティアに参加した人たちは
たけさん
と美香さんの温かさやレタ
の笑顔に魅了されていきます日に日にその
人数が増えていきました人数
が増えていったので交流会をするように
なりましたその交流会も規模が大きくなっ
ていったので地域の神社を借りて地域のお
祭りに発展していきましたまたその
ボランティアさんの融資で水槽楽団が結成
されました今やその水槽楽団は定期演奏会
をするほどまでに発展していきまし
た障害はハードルになることもあります今
の階段とか信号というものは2速歩行が何
なくできる人が暮らしやすいようになって
います
例えばアクシデントがあって一時期車椅子
生活
をしてみるそうするとちょっとの段差が
あるだけで生活がしにくいんですねでその
生活がしにくいという点ではレタの障害は
弱みなのかもしれませ
んでもたさん
とガさんはそのレータの弱みを強みに変え
ていきましたレータに障害があることを
公表して地域の人たちを巻き込んでいった
の
ですたさんと伊賀さんお2人で始めた
レータのストレッチそれが約20年の時を
経て200人以上の人がそのストレッチに
参加してくれるようになっていきまし
たレタに障害があるということを公表する
そういう冒険に出た結果そこに人を集めて
ご縁をついでいくことができたの
です冒険に出るから感じられることがある
冒険に出るから出会える人がいる冒険に
出るから伝えられることが
あるあなたが
持つ弱みは出していきましょうそして冒険
に出ることで強身に変えていき
ましょうさてえ僕のトークも終盤に入って
きましたここで僕僕からお勧めする冒険の
出方をご紹介しますそれは簡単なことです
ちょっとずつと言いますスモールステップ
とも言い
ます質問があって喋ることが苦手な僕が
コミュニケーションを避けなくなった理由
それは僕の話を最後まで聞いてくれる家族
がいたからです
次
に僕の話を最後まで聞いてくれる仲間がい
いたから
ですそして
今僕の話を最後まで聞いてくれるように
変わっていく子供たちがいるからです僕は
ちょっとずつハードルを乗り越えてきまし
たスモールステップを踏んできましただ
から今日このような舞台でお話ができる
ようになりまし
たまずはあなたにとっての最も小さい
ステップを見つけてくださいそしてその
そのステップを踏むことができればずっと
次のステップも見えてくるはず
ですそして冒険に出る最初のステップは今
すぐできることをお勧めします
例えばこのトークの後隣に座ってる知ら
ない人にお話をしてみてください僕の
トークの感想でもいいですお尻が痛いなと
かでもいい
ですその一言が冒険に出るきっかけに
変わっていくかもしれませ
ん最後に僕からお願いがあります冒険に
出るためには勇気が
必要ですだからもし冒険に出てる人を
見かけたらそれをそれをう受け入れてあげ
て欲しいの
ですもしこのトークの後誰かに話しかけ
られたらそれを笑顔で聞いてあげて
くださいそしてあなたからも一言話をして
みて
ください知らない人と喋るということ
つまり冒険に出るということはは誰だって
不安
ですでもその行動が自分の殻
を破って可能性を無限に広げていってくれ
ますそれこそ冒険に出るということです僕
はこれからも冒険に出続けていきます
あなたも一緒に冒険に出ていきません
か
ご清聴ありがとうございまし
[拍手]
た